hello everyone and welcome to the most
important match of the day it is Arjun
irrigation versus Magnus Carlsen and it
is the second match of the finals of the
Julius bear generation cup uh in the
first match Magnus won convincingly he
won the first game he won the second
game and then the third game ended in a
draw uh Magnus had some winning chances
but um uh Arjun was able to get a draw
that game and the fourth game was not
even played as uh with two and a half
half you don't really have a chance of
bouncing back within the four games and
now this is the first game of the second
match so now Arjun needs to win this
match in order to force tie breaks and
hopefully try and win the match so let's
see how it how it went Arjun has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to
D4 now will he be able to forget that
he's actually playing Magnus or will he
you know just focus on chess let's let's
find out Magnus replies with the D6 and
now Arjun uh just transposes into the
piece defense he pushes E4 and of course
it makes sense this is the absolute best
reply Knight to F6 we have Knight the C3
and the G6 by Magnus with Bishop to E3
and pawn to C6 Queen to D2 so also a
fairly standard stuff uh Jurgen Castle
Queens that play King B1 play F3
hopefully
uh start pushing on the king side Magnus
plays Knight B to D7 and here Queen side
Castle so now just B5 so a similar to
what they already played in this event
in the preliminaries they faced each
other in round one where Magnus won
incredibly convincingly with the black
pieces so let's see what Arjun prepared
for uh for uh for his revenge with Pont
F3 Knight to B6 by Magnus and now Pawn
to H4 and there is one game uh where H5
was played and interestingly H5 is the
top move recommended by the engine it
was played in a game between uh Diana
artunova and Ivan rosum in 2006
um in the gene of cup that ended by
black winning but here we have Pawn to
B4 Magnus immediately goes for the
counter attack and it is now already as
of move 8 that we have a completely new
game so the Knight is attacked the
Knight has to retreat Knights the B1
this is the best Square for the night we
have Ponte A5 and now Knight the H3
Magnus strikes in the center D5 invites
E5 which is what Arjun does Knights the
H5 now making G for impossible even
though you would really like to play
this but then Knight the G3 attacks The
Rook Delight core version already you
are not getting the positions you want
so here Queen to E1 controlling the G3
square but now Magnus just uh grabs the
Knight Bishop captures The Rook captures
and now plays Knight back to G7 and how
can you uh of course uh continue the
attack because that's what you want to
do Carlson's King is still in the center
of the board but it seems like he's
Untouchable uh one a very interesting
idea is to push H5 but it's it's not a
move you will play in a rapid game
without actually preparing it for
example H5 Knight captures and now not
you what you would expect the G4 simply
keeping the H file open for you for your
rook and then good things might happen
but it's um even though the engine likes
this it really makes no sense so here
Arjun just continues with Bishop to H6
Magnus plays Knight E6 offers a trade of
Bishops and yes he's bereft of of
castling rights but it doesn't matter he
controls the F4 square and Arjun will
not be able to start pushing those
spawns so here how can he do it he can
play G3 and then push F4 but then G3
will prevent his Rook from ever going
Queen side because Magnus might also
play something like Queen C7 castles and
then you really want to be able to shift
this Rook over to help out with the
attack or with the defense on the queen
side so here Arjun finds Rook to H2
which is also a fine idea and the
situation on the clock is Arjun has some
8 minutes and 30 seconds and Magnus has
12 minutes and 30 seconds we have Queen
to C7 and now preparing to push C5 Rook
to C8 you want to open up the attack
towards the white king and C1 H5 by
Arjun and now just Pawn to C5 asking
what do you do with the D4 Pawn your D4
Pawn is hanging uh can you defend it do
you want to play somebody Bishop B5
check it's interesting but a king d8 and
there's really
no good follow-up that you still have to
figure out how to deal with the with the
D4 Pawn so Arjun just captures D
captures and C5 we have Queen captures
and now H captors on G6 captures and now
Pawn to G3 so now he will have access to
the the df4 square and his Rook is also
helping out with the defense of the C2
Pawn which is very important as Magnus
plays Rook to C8 now without the Rook
there there would already be a mating
thread Here and Now Pawn to F4 and now
uh what does Magnus play here Magnus
plays the Knight to D4 you could also
consider maybe playing
um uh some other ideas you don't have to
jump in with the knife right away but it
does make sense you could also just
continue maybe King D7 and maybe play
Rook C7 maybe bring the other Rook to C8
maybe double up on the C file or rather
triple up on the C file but Magnus feels
that Knight the D4 is sufficient and now
you have many many problems and it's not
easy to solve them one of them obviously
is just what happens if Knight captures
and C2 there's too much stuff attacking
C2 so let's say you play something like
Bishop to A6 or even Queen captures and
C2 is possible then Rook captures Rook
captures will be Checkmate so of course
um you don't want to play a silly move
like that what you can do is play Queen
to F2 and this is the only good move for
Arjun uh just guarding that C2 Square
three times by the queen king and rook
and now Magnus plays a beautiful move
Pawn to B3 uh also possible maybe would
be just if this was a classical game you
would go maybe Knight F5 or for a queen
trade and you know just enjoy your
position but it's a rapid game Magnus
plays B3 and he makes Arjun really work
uh for his meal if he wants to save the
game and it's not easy how do you how do
you deal with this best way to continue
this uh this um uh would be not the
capture of course if you capture it
captures the Knight captures on B3 is
made in one now of course the pawn
cannot capture and the Knight covers D2
and C1 so not that but what you could do
after B3 and this is by far the best for
Arjun is Knight to C3 now you allow
Knight captures and C2 and now you trade
Queens Queen captures Rook captures
eight captures on B3 attacking the
Knight and after the Knight moves
attacking The Rook you play Bishop to B5
check first and after King moves now you
move the rook and now okay the game
continues black is slightly better
uh maybe but it's a complete mess of a
position so this is best for Arjun but
Arjun plays just A4 and now it's very
very hard to defend this position Magnus
just plays Queen captures and C2 he's
more than willing to go into this end
game being up material Queen captures
Knight captures with Bishop to B5 with
check King to d8 and now Knight the C3
we have Pawn to E6 adding more defense
to the D5 pawn and now King the B1
getting the king away from that C file
King the E7 by Magnus and now Knight to
E2 and now what do you play here well
there are two ways to play this and when
I was watching the game I was really
thinking about uh how you know in the
olden days for example in the age of
Paul Murphy he Murphy will always play
the most complicated line and Dazzle
everyone and everyone will be like wow
morphe what a what a magician uh there
is a a very fine line of Rook the C5
with the idea of just sacrificing The
Exchange here and it's not easy to deal
with this for example Knight C1 you have
to play something you go after the B3
Pawn Rook captures on B5 and after he
captures A4 uh Defending Your pawn and
now once something is played by white as
there are really aren't all that many
choices you play A3 and then after B
captures you will go Knight to A4 taking
away all the squares in front of the
white king and now after Knight D4
offering a trade of knights also
attacking the B3 Pawn you will play
Knight captures and A3 check King A1 and
now just Knight the C4 uh preparing to
push that pawn to B2 and of course if
Knight captures then Knight comes the C3
takes away all of the squares from the
white king then Rook to A8 is coming uh
absolute Madness but uh Magnus plays a
move that for example would be played by
let's say Jose row capablanca if you
remember during The capablanca Saga that
we've covered caboblanca was often
criticized even though he pretty much
won every game but that he wasn't um uh
you know playing flashy sacrifices
wasn't uh dazzling the viewers but
sometimes capablanca would just win a
game in the most simple simplest of ways
and then he would also demonstrate after
the game how he could have won let's say
by sacrificing a piece or something but
Magnus just plays a rook to h8 and it's
a very very principled uh decision that
really shows you how Magnus plays if you
if you remember I often like the uh I
often like the
uh quote for example let me just even
update this yeah I was thinking about
updating this I I forgot about it but
yeah I often like the quote Josh
waitskin as I really enjoyed all of his
um all of his lessons on the on the old
chess master uh just waiting and used to
say that you know if you're struggling
to find the move uh think about the
principle of the least active piece and
here if you look at magnus's pieces this
Knight is very active Rook is very
active then I could be more active but
it's not the least active piece The Rook
on f8 however is uh Black's least active
piece and now Magnus just plays Rook to
h8 so just by knowing the principle the
move comes to mind and the Magnus plays
it so he makes just look very simple and
okay now you're countering arjun's Rook
that is very very active and Arjun
trades if you don't trade I just uh give
the the H file to Magnus so Rook
captures nh8 Rook captures an h8 and now
Knight the C1 going after the B3 pawn
and now Magnus plays Knight E3 goes
after The Rook on D1 uh situation on the
clock three minutes for Arjun and 8
minutes for Magnus we have Rook D1
attacking the Knight now Knight Sita E4
just defending the Knight here and uh
sorry night um uh knight uh eat the C4
uh getting back and now the question is
can uh Arjun play Knight captures on B3
yes he can and he most definitely should
but that also means that the knight from
C4 attacking the B2 Pawn will help out
the rook and then once the Rook comes to
H2 it's very hard to defend this
position you could also wait play King
A1 and then like be ready uh if if Rook
to H2 then you can maybe block with Rook
D2 but then it moves like Rook to D to
come to mind now the pawn is protected
and if Rook to D1 then you play Rook to
H2 and there really isn't a move Arjun
can play here and the Magnus will just
slowly build up an attack against uh the
base of the pawn chain here start
gobbling them up one by one it's it's a
very slow death so after Knight eat the
C4 Arjun goes for the pawn Knight
character zombie 3 and now Rook the H2
Magnus goes after the B2 Pawn King to C1
and now Magnus plays King to f8 there's
no rush in capturing the B2 Pawn this
can never be defended but the Magnus is
just asking what do you play is there a
move that you can play that will improve
your position most likely it will worsen
your position so here another example of
a nice principle the threat is stronger
than the execution so Rook to F1 Arjun
uh ready to lift that Rook over to F3 to
help out with the defense of the queen
side and the G3 Pawn you could also play
something like Rook D1 but then just
Rook G2 puts pressure on the pawn here
and if Rook to D3 yes it's possible the
pawn is protected but then you will lose
the the B2 Pawn so you know it's a
trade-off but okay Rook Def One by Arjun
uh now Magnus finally captures Knight
captures on B2 Knight captures on A5 and
not Knight to do captures on A4 grabbing
that pawn Rook to F3 adding uh more
defense to the third Rank and now just
Knight the C5 we have rooked the C3
going after the night but now Magnus
just plays Rook to A2 saying that if you
if you capture here it's just lost
because if you capture magnets will
capture an A5 and now you can never move
the bishop because the Rook hangs and
you can never move the Rook because the
bishop hangs then it would be a fairly
easy way to to win this to give an
example it's the king C2 Magnum starts
bringing the king into the game King B3
uh Knight to D7 now attacking the rook
and there's really no good move you have
to attack the black Rook here and then
after captures captures this is a
winning end game for for Magnus let's
say G5 attacks the pawn because the
Knight is coming to E4 we'll put
pressure on G3 and ifletic King before
night the knights the E4 attacks the G3
pawn and if F captures King G6 now
you're just gonna gobble up all of the
pawns uh easily winning end game so
after Rook day two knights the C6 is an
attempt by Arjun and it's it's a valiant
one uh Knight to E4 by Magnus attacking
the rook and the G3 Pawn Rook the B3 and
now Rook the G2 putting more pressure to
the G2 Pawn Bishop to A6 opening up an
attack on the B6 Knight now Knight to A4
we have rooked the B8 check King to G7
and now Knight to E7 and it looks very
dangerous Rook to Jade is coming upon is
covering F6 problem is Magnus always has
the H7 and um
uh H6 squares so Knight ate the C5
Magnus puts pressure on the bishop and
now there is no good way to play this if
you defend or move you're just playing
over sand game so Arjun gives it one
last attempt Rook to G8 with check and
now King the H7 also King to H6 is fine
but Magnus goes King to H7 uh Rook the
f8 now attacking the F7 pawn and now
Magnus has to decide whether to capture
the the bishop or to try and Checkmate
the white king with the two knights and
The Rook it's possible to do this but it
requires calculation and Arjun was very
low on time zone 30 seconds on the clock
so uh Magnus just picks up the free
piece but you know for your viewing
pleasure I will show it if Knights the
B3 check King to D1 Rook to D to Chuck
King the E1 now Knights the D4 you allow
one check here and after Rook captures
King day trade Knight captures and G6
you play King the G8 and now there is
nothing you can do the Rook is hanging
if you move the Rook with check then
King G7 will attack the Knight and the
and if you move the Rook of course then
it's game over just Knights to D3 Knight
to F3 with Chuck King to F1 and then
Knight captures and G3 will be Checkmate
or or something like that you could also
play a rook to F2 Checkmate so there are
many checkmates in the position so I
have to Rook the Fate Magnus says all
right I mean I'm not going to calculate
this I'm just going to pick up the free
Bishop Rook captures an F7 King h8 now
comes Knight captures and G6 but now of
course King to G8 The Rook now hangs you
have to play a move Rook the A7 and now
Knight 8 to C5 and here Arjun played
Pawn to F5 and now uh Magnus will get
his checkmate with with the two knights
and The Rook but you will also have to
work for it so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the correct
continuation it's a forced Checkmate in
three so have at it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the first
made in three and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Knight the D3 with checked this
is what Magnus played and it was in this
position on move 48 that Arjun
irrigation resigned the game uh as uh
there is nothing more to be done here so
of course if the if the king moves to D1
then it's a very nice Knight the C3
Checkmate all of the squares are covered
by the knights and The Rook of course
prevents the the king from going up the
board and if after Knight to D3 check
you play King the B1 then it's a very
nice Knight the C3 check King the A1 and
now the knights are covering uh A2 and
B2 and of course Rook to G1 will be
Checkmate so after Knight E3 Arjun
resigned and a tough start for Arjun in
the second match Magnus takes a win in
the first game with the black pieces so
now uh Arjun will have to really pull
like a really really big rabbit out of a
hat if he wants the bounce back in this
match but if anyone can do it he can
he's been playing incredible of chess
for the past two years uh let's see what
happens and will he make Magnus really
really you know work for his meal uh
instead of just you know winning the
first two games and it's over so we'll
see what happens the match is still
young Anything Can Happen let's enjoy
some chess uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it um yeah I I
thought this was just a very very nice
moment here uh when an id2 was played
with the Rook to C5 was a possibility
but Magnus just chooses the simplest
possible option I mean
um it really makes you think about your
own games where you know you you feel
like it's a complicated position but if
you think about the the principle of the
least active piece you just play a movie
and it's the strongest move recommended
by the engine that's how how Magnus
rolls uh so yeah uh once again really
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Mexico David Kimura Don relics and
Henry Spraggins for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event uh until it finishes
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day